始めたね質問です3型のようにはプール
作らないんですかいやだが膨れないことも
ないんですけども作るとにばがプールで
埋まっちゃうんでちょっともったいない
なって気がしております
これじゃあ端ですようこそ平成を生きた皆
さんたぶんこの動画を見ている方は
ほとんど平成というものを経験した人も
いるでしょ0橋塚知らない皆さん関連
じゃあはじめじゃあちょっとプッ
というわけで平成時代が拾った前節内でも
皆さんまだ覚えてますでしょうか saw
her スペシャル vs ハウスピン
ながらもかなり大勢の湯チューバーが
ハンドスピナーが流行っているこれも
ハンドスピナーの動画私は再生数とれる
ちゃうということでもう擦って擦って
こすりまくられたいにしえのアイテムそれ
がハンドスピナー何が遅いが悪いません
あの僕もその中の一人です何だ代表格せ
なけれ出回ってるものって何か御用されて
いて素敵だなぁと思って僕も何回か動画に
させていただいたんですけども今平成じゃ
ねぇ
例はね素敵でハンドスピナー流行った時代
から結構の守護年ぐらい経ってる気がする
んですけど平和が反発みなみなさん知って
ますごく最近ネットでなんとなくハンド
セミナーで調べてたんですけども
こ1滴でアマゾンでもこれはどう見ても
ヤバイというか今まで見たことないみたい
な箱積みの今回何種類か買ってきたので俺
もちょっとよくわかんないのとかあるから
それをちょっと一緒に見ていければいいな
と思いますデー子
紙類
的にまずどれから異国からこれから行こか
なこちらで何かちっちゃいよねよここに俺
が買ってきた話皆はマジで
伊吹見たことないやつでした茶1個目に
行かせていただきますオープンプライス
あれこれは中もミスったかな
うさーですこれハンド好きなんですパン
ドンスぺーある定義はもう名前の通りで系
の中で回ればハンド好きなんですよこれで
ハトメただのユルヤナんですけども大木の
指にはめますよどこに入るんだろう小指と
かな小指ちょうどいい感じですねで午後
回るんですね
これて出回ってるんでハンドスピナーです
ほんと1個魅力大丈夫かねこれ本当に声で
大丈夫かねごめんね指がこの上の部分だけ
ここで回転させてから暇な時とはこうやっ
て回転吸ったら面白いなみたいな女かな
人目に付かないちょっとファッションな
感じのハンドスピナらしいです一応ハンド
スピだよね訛ってるしはいん
失礼致しましたようで次行きましょうこれ
かなり重厚なアタッシュケースのような箱
に入っておりますこちらが2個目ですあげ
ていきましょうか
大
すごいんだぞオーナーけね普通なんのすけ
が付いてましたぐうっこれすごいぞずん人
に色がすごいなぁと思ってちょっと買って
みました綿花さあこんな色の花趣味があっ
たっけって思うんですけどこれがまぁ
あのーあるみたいな感じですね茶色がっぽ
金3 c みたいでこれがまあ聖堂と言わ
れる形かなこれがなんか花日は見ていった
性質でこれが船の舵みたいな感じかなに
これ
昆虫みたいですごい奴だまわしてみたいと
思いますまずはこれから
基本的な使わせましょうか
いきます
めっちゃ綺麗なんだけど6使い天井
何なんか今日が入れない昔の判断するなよ
が blitz は回転力だっている2個
のモノ自体がいいかなすごい
おおーー
めっすぎですごいなーなんか全部色が違う
のがまたすごい普通に何か綺麗でハマっ
ちゃうタイプこれ
[音楽]
平成に割ったかなちょっとあのいろんな
バリエーションはじゃあ見てなかったん
ですけどここまでさあこんなさーん
グラデーションメタリカ並みで熱って
あんま見たことなかったんで何か新しいな
と思っ直轄でみました1個持ち歩こうはい
みなさんまだまだですよまだすごいなり
ますから次は the これいきますか俺
反応ピラーっいいのかなぁ俺は坂路住み
なって検索して出てきたので俺はずだって
ならと思ってましたからなぁちょっとどう
なんでしょうねいきますよこちらはい
zippo こそですなんかすごいジっ
ぽくない何かライターっぽいというか部は
見た目こんな感じになってますちょっと
動かしてみるね行きません
これなんか
ほれしっかっ綺麗になったりとかこれ
なんかあのう
わかりましたね
底に良い日に tk 打ってるからこう
やってね一生形がカーれ続けるという9分
になっています見た目も超かっこいいん
ですけどもけの中で回り続けているという
ことで一応なんかハンドスピナーっていう
本膳つの中らしいよ知らんけど俺はあなた
ので話になって消えた記者らプロが出てき
たからと抱っこいいねぇハンドセミナーで
結局さが暇な時にやるもんだからそういう
面ではこれはもうほぼハンドスピナーと
言っても過言ではないかという
[音楽]
これハマるねずっとレッダーって触って
たいもこれなんかああああみんな富山次
行けなくなりました2つ技これいきます
これもちゃんとハンドセミナーって書いて
あるからもれっきとした犯罪ってなんだと
思いたい行きます
あっはぁ
うわぁこれなんだっけなぁコレナンダッケ
なんで買ったんだっけ c ホールダー
みたいになってるんですよって本体がこう
いう感じで船の風みたいになってますけど
もあそうだこれねサイコロなんですよ
サイコロの帰りになるみたいな患者そびー
なす周りに1から6まで2違ってて
それがが止まったところが数字になる
みたいな感じです岩だったら4かな最後の
ないとこれでやっとルールって言ってる
すごいよねなんかさ土台に乗ってるハンド
市湊来れなかったんだと思う結構されてね
普通に感動しましたねこれはカバンには
付けませんというわけで是非行きましょう
かこれはもう俺たちのハンドスピナー子ら
にはなかったなっていうやつですこちら6
が肉カラフルなハンドスピナーですそう
まるで例はを象徴するような子の多様化し
た社会を表すかのような自由さん
ダサい8 e 3でですいい意味でダサい
ですかながら瀬木ルシコフくらいあんなん
これはほとんどありするってことを
そういうわけではないとりあえず色を入れ
ておけばいいだろうそんな暑さの心の声が
聞こえますそこ色ティア do 阿部次で
改定しちゃうとすごい金具ですねあー
すごいすごいすごい
目が痛くなるような色だ多分なんですけど
この名が付いているこのボタンでナイス
あるんですけど本当なら手持ちぶさターナ
1ように作ってやったのこのなんか勝ち発
して描きまになんないよーみたいな感じ
らしいですなぜ色厚号湯でもう本当に売れ
面たくなるでしょだから彼ですけどサティ
かちょっとコーンなーのーまで出てるよっ
ていうこの例の時代でございますまあで
あります雪がこれですねこれはねちょっと
で使い方セラもよくわかってないよって
買いましたカラーリングがまず
動いたけどこれすごい形は結構普通のし
家庭なんですけども何回は動いていっ
これどこか入ってんのこれ
ええええ
そこ改定前の全く手を歳過ぎこれすごい
叱っていいかと思ったなぁ
[音楽]
周りが回転してますねこれパッド h の
四角形なんてキューブなんですけども
cocco 持ってここを改定するって
言う
[音楽]
カッコイはこれちょっと俺の中で優勝です
ねもあまりにオサレすぎるパンが好き日
パンダ住みなあかんがな違反の罪な朝礼
こそがレイバーのハンドスピナーだと思っ
ていますここらへんとのマジでかっこいい
なやっぱ仕掛けていってねこれは怪しい
ですけどすげー大きいと思ったら中野字
ックだけ改定させるものでよくてがなく
かなりの売っちゃいいんだよなこの
グラデーションメタリックいてなうわー
いいなーかっこいい絵めっちゃいいじゃん
これちょっとこれはかなりではぽかった気
がしますけどもなんか凄いのが残ってる
最後はもうこれはね俺はびっくりしたの見
たとき一応3種類あってね3種類ことを
買わせていただきましたそちらです
これ
俺もよくわかんないですけどもタブー
ロボットに変形するハンド好きなて水く
開けてみますね
はいっ
認め結構なんか水道ぽい形でしますけども
能見したりあもう全部伸びちゃう
とかまあるってことだから形が自由なわけ
ですよ自分の好きな形にできるからの各
こういう形にもできるっていう
そしたらホラー
肌使いでも回るっていう逆にをこういう形
にもできるっていうちょっと危険全部開け
ときますねん
いやもうすごいなぁどんな形にはなるな
こうするともうロボットみたいな形でも
なくてこの半年が経つんですよこんなに
ga 度が高いほど少ないままでありまし
たその一応ちゃんと形付ければ
回転をするっていうこれはワシが生きた
時代にはなかったなぁとは思いますね私
入っており今でさあこういう形の話皆を
作れるわけですよすごいなって黒子って
回転する
愛知ようできますねすごくねどんな形でも
されるって個人的にはなんかめっちゃ目力
を感じましたね合体とかできないかの層は
さすがに無理かなとれそうだけどこれ言っ
ていいのか
一体ためだねこれ重ねて多くとても楽し
そうですね
あっあっ
みなさんこれハンドセミナーですね
ああああずっといましたよズってくれます
から
最後のずいぶん
[音楽]
大入らないと
pa あああああっあっー
方みなさんこれ飯山見ないよたいという気
で様々なレイバン半年皆紹介しました
ごめんなさい平成にあったものとかもある
と思うんですけども前年でもやハンド
スピナーが流行ってた時に比べて相当
変わってると思いますちょっとこれからも
例はの新月でハンドセミナー引き続き私
反応しミーナ隊長として今後新しいのでな
調査していきたいとおもいますじゃあ
あっ
[音楽]
は
blr